[Music]
welcome back to Hannity so with a
declining population it is no secret
that Americans are now fleeing
California and droves despite its vast
natural resources great weather
beautiful Coastline now California is
shrinking rapidly but it's not just
people businesses also are leaving the
state look at this according to one CBS
report approximately 65
000 have left since 1990 and that Exodus
continues to this day and is especially
palpable in San Francisco the city's
Fame Union Square neighborhood is Now
quickly turning into a ghost town with
19 major store closures since 2020. so
what's going on in the Golden State and
will the state's Governor take any
responsibility here's part two of my
interview with Governor Gavin Newsom
let me ask about quality of life issues
when you have I'll give you these back
by the way I'm well aware of these
things I think if you put them around
the governor's mansion this is going to
be a classic interview you know listen
it may seem and you're very I appreciate
your passion for your state I love it I
appreciate the fact that you fight for
your the things you believe in yeah you
know and this goes back to the original
premise of not only this discussion
because this really is a friendly
discussion no I know there's no personal
animus between us it's just I don't
agree with your your views you're very
good at giving reason rationale for
losing population and higher state
income tax and and now I'm going to ask
you about the homeless population but
you have stores now in San Francisco
because of Smash and grab robberies
they're leaving yeah you know Walgreens
is one I think target is the other
there's at least three Whole Foods is
another you're leaving San Francisco
okay so my question to you is between
taxes bureaucracy crime homelessness and
the homeless numbers are not really good
no uh for you in your state versus I
acknowledge that and no I mean I
wouldn't compare ourselves to anyone
it's a disgrace the homeless issue in
2008 you had a 10-year plan yeah I got
the tape let me play it for you do it
San Francisco We Believe fundamentally
that food solves hunger that shelters
soft sleep and that housing solves
homelessness and if we're to solve the
problem of those that are out on the
streets that we Define as homeless we
better solve the housing problem if
we're going to have an impact and that's
why we established this framework what
we call a 10-year plan to end chronic
homeless in San Francisco
it's in San Francisco
okay now here we are you want to know
the results after 10 years okay
I don't need to look at you don't like
my charts I know the charts I know these
charts so well after 10 years we've
reduced the street population by 33 you
know what I'm proud of the fact we
established the goal we did it with the
with the Bush Administration with
Republicans we did it with a framework
where we actually identified by Georgia
W bush is one of the leaders in terms of
establishing not only a framework of a
plan but delivering on what we promoted
in promise and I agree with you you know
Michelangelo said it best biggest risk
in life is not that we aim too low and
reach it so we aim too high and miss it
rather the opposite my point being we
have to be audacious and in so doing we
actually made progress this state has
not made progress in the last two
decades as it relates to homelessness
why because housing costs are too high
are regulatory thickets are too
problematic localism has been two
impactful meaning people locally are
pushing back against new housing starts
in construction I've been here four
years I can't make up for the fact in
2005 we had an historic number of
homeless under Republican right now
there's 171 thousand that's crazy okay
it's graceful and all right I'll compare
to Florida again 26 000. of course okay
same weather similar State I mean I've
lived in both Dynamics are very
different that said we own this Sean I'm
not I'm not here to defending it but
here's the difference you're going to
build 1200 homes this year I read that's
not true you have a proposal sixty eight
thousand people off the streets last
year and by the way that's been
politifacts 68 000. we had we had I have
a 15.3 billion dollar homeless plan when
I got here was half a billion dollars
the state of California was not involved
in the homeless issue we got involved
we're holding cities and counties
accountable I'm suing cities and they're
not producing housing housing we
actually have a 15-year high and new
housing starts in the state of
California we're actually seeing
programs produce Real Results but I want
accountability I'm not the mayor of
California I'm governor of Six States
larger than 21 States populations
combined and the difference between me
and most politicians is I own
I take responsibility for this this is
personal on me I love this state I don't
like what's happening with the
encampments I like what's happened the
streets and sidewalks I don't like the
bashing of mild City San Francisco all
foods did shut down one business but
there was a bad location to begin with
they're opening a new one we have two
point sisters out here recently with
their team and I said don't go to the
wharf certain parts are bad and we own
that and I just put the National Guard
and the CHP down there hundreds of
millions I know and by the way you
mentioned defund police don't accuse me
of that I've never been part of that say
yeah I'm saying you didn't want to build
any more border wall that court I have
because it was it was sort of farcical
this notion that somehow you're gonna
have a physical structure that's 2 000
miles long why not with all due respect
I sit here watching the former president
say he did it and somehow Mexico paid
for it it's laughable those assertions
you got a better trade deal with Mexico
and Canada I'm not here to take cheap
shot on that flight
and coming up next you are an open
Sanctuary State you should why don't you
Embrace about dealing with the cards
that are dealt and for comprehensive
immigration reform I'm proud of our
president for putting a strategy out and
you guys have been silenced on it you
haven't even discussed it yet a
sanctuary State why don't you embrace
them and say thank you for sending them
I wasn't we Embrace everybody here we
deal with the cards a date in a human
way
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else